[Music]
a group of parliamentary committees led
by the committee on international trade
has heard and questioned valdis
dombrovskis
ursula fond alliance proposed candidate
for the post of trade commissioner
europe needs to become more assertive by
protecting our companies
securing our strategic interests
strengthening reciprocity and
leveling the playing field dombrovskis a
former latvian prime minister has been a
commission vice president since 2014
until the reshuffle prompted by the
resignation of phil hogan
he held the finance portfolio a position
set to be filled by marrade mcginnis
we live in unprecedented times we face
increased challenges at home and abroad
working together
we can design a strong european plan to
address these challenges
working together by can future-proof
europe's trade
policy in the hearing meps questioned
his position on relations with china and
the u.s
greening trade policy europe's small
businesses
fair trade and the relationship with the
uk after brexit
progress will depend on both sides
respecting their commitments
under the withdrawal agreement both the
commission and the parliament have been
very clear on this point
parliament will vote on whether it
considers donbroska suitable for the
commission post
[Music]
you